thank you for joining us North Korean
state media says leader Kim jong-un has
made his first public appearance in
nearly three weeks these images were
broadcast on state television they
appear to show kim opening a fertilizer
factory speculation about the leaders
health and whereabouts had been growing
after he failed to appear at birthday
celebrations for his late grandfather
last month let speak to our
correspondent Rob McBride who's in Seoul
South Korea Rob taka sulfurous what
we're seeing in these images have been
broadcast on state television and will
they finally silence the rumors about
Kim jong-un's health Kim jong-un
seemingly in perfectly good health it
seems especially given some of the
reports had him barely clinging to life
just a couple of days ago this was a big
stage on which to re-emerge into public
view the opening of a large impressive
fertilizer plant with cheer cheering
crowds this all happened yesterday a
Friday May the 1st in North Korea it was
widely reported on KCNA the official
North Korean news agency and now they're
running extensive video footage on North
Korean state-run television it is being
run quite quickly compared to how North
Korean and the media machine often work
so it is possibly possible that it is
putting out these image images to quash
as convincingly as possible all of these
rumors that have been swirling about
Kim's health Kim jong-un appeared that
the the ribbon-cutting ceremony he was
accompanied by his sister kim yo-jong he
seems to be in good health he seems to
be alert he was interacting
good-naturedly with officials other
officials were seen around him
diligently taking notes as he gave field
instruction as is often the case on
these visits he was seen touring the
plant on some of the sequences where we
see him walking he was moving quite
slowly but then Kim does move quite
slowly in any case so he does seem to be
in good health the unification ministry
here in South Korea has confirmed that
this event has all taken place we only
have of course the reports that come
from state-run media
in North Korea but officials here in
South Korea have confirmed it and also
used the event to criticize some of the
speculation that there has been by
various new sites portals news
organizations saying that this was a lot
of it groundless content which did very
little it was caused unnecessary
confusion but of course because he
missed that all-important ceremony the
birthdate celebration of Kim il-sung the
founder of North Korea and his
grandfather that did lead to all of this
speculation varying from the fact that
he had some sort of operation some sort
of possible cardiovascular procedure
that possibly went wrong right up to
reports that he could have been brain
dead but all of that seemingly to be
perfectly premature right while the
North Koreans certainly very keen to
dispel the rumors but there is so the
question robbed of who would replace kim
jeong-hoon if he were to die what do we
know about that the succession plan
absolutely this is a very timely
reminder just of the precarious nature
of North Korean leadership politics and
the fact that there is this huge cult
surrounding the North Korea's leader
that does raise the big question what
would happen there in the vacuum of the
void that would be left behind and there
isn't in North Korea at the moment as
seemingly an heir apparent we know that
kim yo-jong his sister probably his
strongest ally in north korea has
possibly been groomed for the position
but it's in no way certain that she
would but she would become the next
leader of North Korea so it has raised
concerns and also raised some issues
about her Kim's health he does appear on
this video still smoking very heavily
and still certainly very overweight
thank you for that Robert bride live for
us in Seoul